one minute he can be the most proper of
gentlemen and the next the most
terrifying of monsters his oscar-winning
performance in Silence of the Lambs gave
new meaning to the term fast-food junkie
and this year the Academy has nominated
him again as leading actor a most
distinguished artist and a fine human
being Academy Award winner Sir Anthony
Hopkins
good evening the category is foreign
language film must be a feature-length
film motion picture produced with the
basically non-english dialogue tract and
the creative talent for exercising
artistic control must be the same as the
submitting country only one picture will
be accepted from each country this year
there were 35 entries five have been
selected at outstanding films by any
standard in the world nominees are
Spain Belle Epoque Fernando suave
director from Hong Kong farewell my
concubine cheap water correct the United
Kingdom South Wales my home country
headwind Paul Turner director from
Vietnam scent of green papaya tan unhung
director Taiwan wedding banquet and Lee
director and the Oscar goes to Belle
Epoque accepting the world directive
another two other
you
and there is go made my friend and my
producer I want to thank you all in the
name of all the friends who made Belle
Epoque some of them are here some in
Spain some in France and some in
Portugal I want to also to thank the
family of Sony Pictures Classics and I
would like to be living off in order to
thank him but I just believe in Billy
Wilder's
so Thank You mr. Weiler
you